[Music]
hello everyone welcome to our talk today
my name is Ellen up Yeshua trbovich I'm
a staff software engineer at Google and
one of the technical leads on cloud
dataflow product today we're going to
look at the data processing tools in
their application their performance and
how to the cloud processing tools data
proc and data flow achieve the excellent
and optimal performance out of the box
so data profit processing performance
why do we care about it well it matters
because it affects the latency of our
result so to achieve our result we have
to spend time running the pipeline and
depending how efficient it is it affects
when our result is available depending
on what your application is the time it
takes to get to the solution can be make
it or break it event for your you know
product another reason why the
performance matters is the cost your
applications run on the real hardware
running on real hardware costs money
whether you use the cloud or you use the
on-premise right so if it's inefficient
you're literally wasting money so that's
important thing and combining these two
it actually makes a performance can make
data analysis feasible or unfeasible if
it's too slow we don't need it if it's
too expensive we cannot afford it so
performance is really critical in making
it possible for us to do a data
knowledge so what are the factors that
affect the performance there are many of
them and first set of factors we're
going to look at are related to your
application essentially the things that
are sort of in your control first thing
is data shape and distribution are your
old data all data records approximately
the same size or they vary vary a lot
right if you think of summin processing
a social graph a node that contains the
social butterfly will be orders of
magnitudes bigger than a node containing
an average person right
the other thing that's sort of similar
but slightly different is the pro record
computation costs distribution do all
records cost the same like does it take
same amount of CPU time to process each
of your records or again there is a big
difference if you think of something
that's processing map tiles like the
processing a map tile on Antarctica
versus processing a map tile in San
Francisco probably encourage different
computation costs and finally in reading
application space the one factories
implementation efficiency right how well
you were at like optimizing it how well
you were it using the api's that are
given to you for how's your memory
management and things like that so to
address the application factors there is
a traditional performance tuning and
optimization process right we profile
our data and we profile the application
now we once we understand our data and
application we can perfectly split our
data partition it for execution in
parallel and we can perfectly schedule
those tasks of course it's perfect take
with a grain of salt like but we can
perfectly schedule the task job will
execute and produce our results and
we'll be happy if that was it like we're
done right we've computed everything we
needed but in reality this is not the
end right we run our data processing
pipelines regularly sometimes even
continually right so this process is the
process it has to be repeated and it
sort of works except expertise is
required right like the person who can
do the profiling in data and application
is not easy to find right and the thing
is like if you have one application sure
you can maybe afford someone who will be
you know your expert and make it run
great but if you have hundreds you
really can scale it so what happens then
is people copy tuning parameters from
the one that was tuned and and then like
you know and it keeps going and you copy
it and you hope that it's going to
achieve the same performance benefit it
did for original pipeline but guess what
it usually doesn't and especially over
time it gets worse and you may not be
even aware of it
so the other aspects of like where the
traditional performance tuning and
optimizations sort of breakdown is that
it's not always possible if you have a
complex pipeline with multiple stages
you may not be able to reliably profile
intermediate stages because that data
depends on actually data that came in
right and if that changes the properties
of the intermediate data change so you
really can't always benefit from this
and finally even if we did everything
perfectly and we had a full knowledge we
are running on real time sis on the real
system on the machines that will have
some things going on on them and they
will not all behave the same and that
brings us to the execution environment
as a factor of our data performance so
big parts of execution environment
factors are workers you know some
workers will be fast some workers will
be slow why who knows there are many
reasons why workers can be slow or
faster for example like a most of the
work nowadays runs in a vm that share
the physical machine and depending on
the quality of isolation you no one can
affect the other right the other thing
that is important is a networking so
network conditions are even less if you
can even less isolate the networks in
terms of the impact and you know someone
else using the same network you do will
affect your performance right and
finally this is like a resource
contention and this can be on any
possible level it can be resource
contention in your code it can be
resource contention in the worker that
you're running it can be resource
contention on a vm or it can be resource
contention on the service that you rely
on imagine you're reading a service that
can support search certain amount of QPS
right and then there is a big user that
comes and pretty much uses up everything
your job all the jobs will slow down
because of that right so the impact of
uneven working performance gets worse
with scale and those law tells us
essentially that
more par lism we have the more serious
bottleneck the serial part of our
application have become yeah okay so how
do we deal with a graduation environment
well I mean you can remove slow machines
that's one but it's not something you
can do on demand and automatically what
people do is usually avoidance
techniques so things like a backup or
worker resets so if your application
could detect that something is going
slow the worker is slow it can choose to
use a different worker or it can
schedule the work done on that worker to
someone else who's faster right and
that's almost it right like from the
dealing with execution environment
another factor that's related to the
execution environment boxes in this is a
system complexity your application uses
an SDK right and when it runs that as
the K it runs from some kind of a worker
harness or your thing that takes your
API calls in and puts them in a system
and that runs in front kind of a
container that runs on a virtual machine
that may be running multiple containers
right and that's ones on a physical
machine that may be running multiple
virtual machines and if you're doing
distributed application it's what there
are multiple physical machines and they
are connected by a network so anywhere
in this stack something going wrong or
something being slow affects everything
above it right okay yes we are not done
with the factors that affect the
performance we have our dependencies and
I mentioned them but like real call them
out here explicitly so one set of what
dependencies is related to the client
libraries you use if you use in
efficient implementation of something it
will affect performance of your
application right and often client
libraries views are like I OU libraries
your connector to something convenient
libraries like a parser or you know like
a formatter and then some domain
specific libraries may be some kind of a
math library or
thing that you may need to actually
compute what you need right system
libraries are similar you know your VMs
and all this come with some predefined
images and they can have a good set of
libraries or not so good set of
libraries okay so to summarize the
factors that affect application
performance are we've seen they can be
static like a system libraries or
something or dynamics like the things
that happened at the runtime which is
which were our worker and execution
environments for example the data
processing tools need to adapt to the
application and the environment and the
underlying system and dependencies
affect application performance right so
with this we'll look at the two specific
Google Cloud processing tools data flow
and data proc and how they tackle
different aspects of the different
factors that affect application
performance so in first we will look at
a cloud dataflow and how it deals with
the purification specific dependencies
and environment and then we look at the
data proc and how it deals with the
system level improvements okay so let's
switch our gear and talk a little bit
about the cloud dataflow cloud dataflow
is a fully managed no ops data
processing it offers unified batch and
streaming product of processing power
and it uses open source programming
model using apache beam its skin
intelligent it's designed to scale to
millions of QPS if you're using it in a
streaming mode and also can run really
large batch jobs so how does the working
with data flow looks like you wake up
and you right here Apache bean pipeline
then you take it and you submit it to
cloud dataflow service the data for
service and it's behind has a bunch of
backends we got to provide many
different services some of which we'll
talk about that are sitting there
waiting for your jobs to come and
schedule so the service will schedule
your job on one of these backends the
backends will take your bean pipeline
run it through graph optimizer do some
other patients
analysis on it and it will come up with
the initial configuration for your job
and we'll start resources for you on
which you will execute that job so it
will start GCS it will start you know
allocate the buckets and everything else
that you may need for this job your job
will start to run you'll access your
inputs there can be an gcp or they can
be external sources will read them
you'll process process process produce
the output and you're done okay so this
is our workflow so what are the benefits
of it right well it's fully managed is
also configured you don't have to worry
about deploying their packages the jar
files pre allocating VMS you just
submitted you're essentially job to the
service and it runs and all the
resources that your pipeline uses are
allocated on demand okay we also do
automatic graphic optimized a execution
graph so we'll talk about that in a
minute we also mitigate the stragglers
dynamically using something called
dynamic worker balancing and we can
automatically scale at one time to match
the throughput your application needs
okay so if you look at these four
benefits three of them are trying to
address the factors that affect the
performance so a patch even look looking
at the optimization the pipeline graph
versus execution graph what a patch it
being gives you is very intuitive
programming model that allows you to
express the complex computations simply
that's great except it's really not the
way you should be running this
application so once we have your
pipeline we run through many of the
optimizations algorithms to provide the
optimal execution graph that we can run
that will produce the output that you
want so this also like in this process
while we are optimizing we try to
estimate what is the initial
configuration for your job that we think
will run as well
now let's look at the dynamic factors
and look at the stragglers so what is a
straggler in this column in this
framework the straggler is a task that
takes longer than the to complete than
the average completion time across all
the workers so here is a graph and I'll
explain it so first on our x-axis we
have time on weigel axis we have workers
this is a gun chart of the state of the
workers at the given time so each of the
horizontal lines representative worker
and the tasks that were running on it at
the given time right like if you do the
vertical cut so what we can see that in
this graph the worker finish the chart
it's a sign start working on the next 10
when is the task start working on the
next time and things are going pretty
smoothly there is not huge variance with
variability between the end times the
execution with the stragglers looks
different like some of the tasks are
taking much longer than the others right
and they are affecting our end time do
they set things happen in the production
or in your real jobs oh yeah they do so
this is a typical MapReduce like
pipeline where you have a read operation
you group it by key and you write it
this is a job with 400 workers running
for about 20 minutes and if you look at
what those 400 workers worked on there
like these huge gaps where many workers
set idly while few other workers were
trying to finish right and this is a big
resource waste right so to address these
issues of stragglers we employ technique
called data a dynamic work rebalancing
so how does it work so looking again on
our graph with the straggler we can see
our completion time is completion time
is of this job or stage will be once the
red chard finishes once the red past
finishes screen so what can we do how
can we address this so first step in
this is a struggler detection you first
have to invent if I problem so we can
right so what data flow does it son
continually monitors remaining amount of
remaining work so I'm imagine we're on
this gray line that respect that shows
our current time and at that time we
check what's the remaining work we this
would be our completion time if we
didn't do anything right so we run our
algorithm to estimate how much work is
remaining and we come up with this
should be our average completion time if
everything was perfectly paralyzed able
and we were able to utilize oil all
eight workers this is when our job would
finish okay so then once we have this
information a worker can say I'm behind
so what i can do is split I can return
fraction of my work so others can work
on it and I can finish what I have in a
given time right and now we rebalance
the work and the situation looks better
it's not perfect but we did save you
know some amount of time and there are
new completion time is there clearly
there is more work to do we should be
able to paralyze this further so guess
what we do so you repeat this process
over and over during the execution of
the of the job and your workers
constantly get filled with the work okay
so what's the impact on a real job this
is again the same application we saw
like a 400 workers spending a lot of
time waiting on others and this is how
this application looks like once you
enable this dynamic rotor balancing so
we say there on five minutes out of 20
supporter but this is the five minutes
out of 400 workers like 3 33 hours from
CPU time so it's another small sailing
right okay now we're seeing how dynamic
worker balancing reduces straggler tail
and keeps worker busy we but it's not
the only thing we do auto scaling allows
us to match the number of workers to the
true put your application needs so
it's kels the number of workers
automatically to ensure the pipeline is
keeping up with the demand it applies to
both batch and streaming but my example
on this graph is seeming so imagine your
application is up and running it has
some kind of a QPS and we run it with
certain number of machines in this case
I think 12 and you know things are going
fine as the QPS increases as you are
getting more hits on your service like
we will grow the number of workers to
maintain the lag of processing low and
once the QPS rate comes down we creat
the number of machines because there is
no need for them to be there you can
keep up with the traffic just with a
much for your machine okay so how does
this to plaintiff look how does the auto
scaling play out in a bad job for
example so we start the job we do some
initial analysis like a sudden during
the optimization and we come up with a
we should run this with the three
workers okay and thanks start running
and things look ok but again we're
continually estimating when we will
finish and at some point we have enough
information to conclude that this is
going to take much longer we should
really be working with hundred workers
so great ok bring up hundred workers the
beauty of gcp and easily scale up right
however the problem in this case is we
don't have hundreds pieces of work we
initially split it into like six or nine
whatever because we fought we needed
three workers and this is where the
dynamic work rebalancing kicks in right
because now you have hundred workers and
you can generate work for them by using
dynamic works or balancing and this is
actually pretty cool we call it out the
tuning like many people call it
achieving things and you can scale up
and scale down as needed this is a job
that started with a tensile workers and
then decided that they need a thousand
and like the blue lines which ovation
but Lou lines are showing essentially
when the dynamic work rebalancing
happened right like these are the points
in time when we decided to split the
work and distribute it further and you
can really stay see that it
going in stages right but uh the
framework is essentially learning what
your application is doing innocence and
like adapting to it right cool so why
does this matter to you okay well
because it you know helps the real
applications run better I hope so we
will look at the one of the case study
there's this application that one of our
sister teams in Cozumel is cares about a
lot so we are with you know monitoring
what that application is doing and it's
a standard ml pre processing pipeline
it's a it's applicable to pretty much
any etl you take a data in some format
and you created a you you convert it
into format you want right so this
particular application takes the data in
tab separated value format and converts
it into tensorflow record format and
input data are click-through logs from
Creedy i think there is the public data
set and the pipe one is reasonably
straightforward this is our pipeline
graph from data flow you I so we have a
stage the treats from text then we
decode it and then we have the Smith
stage called analyze and transform and
then we encode the output and we write
it and we make a small side output with
some metadata they're just like store
some information about the run this is a
pre-processing step that can apply to
many many users and those users will
differ on input sizes and the content of
the files and they will also differ on
analysis parameters they want to do
right like this analyzing transfer step
is a meat of transformation right and it
has something like you know what is the
threshold for merging two things how big
you know output files you want or two
things like that right and users may
want to configure the application
differently these are not tuning
parameters these are application
parameters that affect what the output
is okay so how would you tune
application to run the best it can given
that the users can set all of these
different things
it's a good question you don't have to
you're using data flow okay so a bit
more of context like so machine learning
workflows for sparse data typically have
three steps you pre process data you
train and you serve the model and in
this case we have only we're looking
only at click-through rates prediction
but if you wanted to do things like
recommendation you would have a
different input tab types that you would
want to add things like the inventory or
user information right and you would
have to perform join which would make
much more complicated pipeline than the
one that we are looking in this example
and for more data details you can see
many of the next ml sessions and
actually the code of application is a
Python SDK bean Python and it's
available in github okay okay again
reflection on a pipeline read decode
analyzing transform and code and right
right so running this pipeline let's
look how it looks like so we have a 10
gigabytes input it's a fraction of the
data set and this is how the worker
profile looks for this pipeline so the x
on x axis we have time this is run from
a week ago or something on the y-axis we
have number of workers and as the
pipeline starts our initial estimated
others should have around 40 workers for
reading and then the blue line actually
shows the workers actual workers the
Green Line is our estimate and what we
want what the system is asking to happen
so the blue line no ramps up to 40 and
then it runs around France and it
figures that I can do you can use a
little bit more parallelism here so it
jumps up and then it once it gets to a
bigger stage like analyzing transformed
thing like it jumps up a lot and it goes
from like around 50 workers two hundred
and seven or eight and then it finishes
in it's done so this job was around 21
minutes 20 seconds and use 38 c 2 hours
and 144 gigabytes of ram and five
terabytes of pd hours
now the same input but with the
different threshold parameters for the
pipeline so this is applications a you
know parameter like I want you to
produce more detailed results it makes
it more expensive to run it or you know
more computational extensive so this is
how that one looks like it looks similar
right but the differences are the y-axis
now goes 250 and above okay and again we
start with them maybe slightly higher
estimates we keep going there is again
that bump when we figure out there might
be some more parallelism here let me
utilize it and then once we get to the
expensive stage like we just you know
ramp up high and then like add some more
and we run it like hundred seventy three
workers and the wrong time is almost the
same 22 minutes 17 seconds but you end
up using way more resources 61 cpu
rs-232 gigabytes of RAM and eight
terabytes of pd my point here is not
that this was more you know
computationally intensive my point is
that it was the same command line as far
as data flow is concerned it was the
only change was in parameters and you
were we were able to keep all these
workers busy for the duration of the
pipeline right there were they were
utilized one hundred percent in terms of
what they are doing so now we want to
look at the larger scale the full input
size is one terabyte what does that do
to the graph there if you changes first
our x-axis go viaccess goes to 1000 this
is a system limit and I'm going to show
it later and when we initially started
we figured out around five between 500
600 workers would be good so we again
start running the first part we had a
bump like every think there is more
parallelism here but then we were like
Aetna we were good so we came back down
and then we have this part which
actually corresponds to a group by
keyshia step what happens in a group by
key step is like you collect all the
data from the from from incoming shards
right and then you have to group them by
key right and this operation is sort of
to step 4
and you cannot proceed the next stage
until you're fully done because you need
to be sure that you saw the keys so what
happened here is that the group by key
couldn't really fully keep up with what
was coming in so it had to finish now
they do use dynamic worker balancing but
there are always more opportunities for
improving and this is one of them so
what happened here is while we were
finishing the tasks that were you know
weren't paralyzed able further we shut
down the other ones there was no reason
for these machines to sit there idle
because they couldn't do anything okay
and then once the that step was done we
should have been parallelism and like we
were using the system imposed maximum we
do not go about thousand workers unless
you tell us just you think it's a
reasonable maximum to have by default ok
so this process this job took 1 hour 33
minutes and use quite a bit of resources
and in terms of scalability the input
ratio size 100 times the CPU ratio size
100 4 times G in terms of gigabytes Rams
use it one hundred and four times as
well and the PD usage was 52 times X and
the wall time ratio was 4.2 right the
ideal scalability in this case we'll do
one right but humble da walls is pretty
strong so this part where we had to shut
down and slow down really does affect
the performance right but we don't waste
resources ok now let's look at the
performance of this application over the
last six months again it's important
application to the to the sister team
and we are with them monitoring what's
happening so the red line shows the
runtime over a six-month period ok the
initial drop there was a bunch of data
flow level improvements that we did on
the Python SDK or beam python sdk after
gia launched so we spend time improving
the connectors and these things and
that's has a very visible impact on the
runtime of the performance notice the
application
did not change in this time period so
these are all the improvements are
happening or all the changes were
happening from system perspective from
from tool perspective right and this
year we enable the auto scaling and that
was another drop in adoration time and
then at this time someone had a
brilliant idea that hey you know we're
looking at the resource usage in this
what does it mean for the cost ok so we
start tracking how much the application
costs at that point and I think in that
moment we were running at 62 minutes
wall-to-wall of all time and it costs
around $225 an end of January we are at
57 minutes so there were no major
reduction in a vault time but our price
is significantly lower and what this
tells you is that the system became more
efficient you're not you know maybe your
vault I'm is that much but you are using
less resources and it's the same
application they're running it
continually essentially right and I
think this is like one of the core
things that I would like you to come out
with this is like we really care about
the cost effective performance and we
treat it as a first-class feature of the
system yeah and with that will fit your
gears and look at our cloud dataflow
data proc product we will look at how
the system level import of improvements
affect the performance in cloud data
procs ok so what is cloud data proc data
proc is brings the wildly use apache
hadoop and apache spark ecosystems to
gcp it is fully managed it's easy to use
it's fast and it's cost effective and
I'll talk about all
so how does the cloud data pro cluster
lifestyle who looks like well when you
need to you start one cluster you then
use it and you run spark how do have any
of these apache open-source ecosystem
the tools and then when you're done you
shut it down you delete the cluster so
it doesn't use your time while you're
using it you can still modify the
cluster so you know your start sort of a
cluster with like 20 machines whatever
now you need 50 and you can pretty
simply change that to a bigger size or
smaller size depending what you need so
this the songs you know this is exciting
I mean if you think you bring up your
cluster you use it you shut it down
there is some like you no power to it
when you do it and but like often
sparking Hadoop record systems are slow
to deploy and they're constantly in
complex so start using delete sounds you
know wasteful if you were going to spend
a lot of time starting the things but
it's not a case with the litter box
right oh and we do one minute billing so
starting a cloud data proc is as simple
literally as going to a web page
clicking create cluster optionally
configuring it and in doing a start and
within a 90 seconds from the beginning
you can have machines sped up like fully
configured whenever you need to change
it you go back to configuration for a
page and you change the parameters that
you want ok so the major goal of data
proc is to bring the power of google
cloud platform spark and Hadoop users
the team builds connectors and
integrations without at all products
like bigquery cloud storage cloud big
table cloth banner compute engine and
allows you to read and write from these
as seemingly one of the example jobs
that they have is like pie sprites job
that takes the data from GCS uses a pie
spark and then produce the output in a
big query
so how does it look like under the foot
so we have our clients on the left hand
side and the Google cloud platform the
right and we have data proc exposes the
rest api for managing the cluster for
managing the jobs and other operations
that you may want to do so you can
access these api is through you I or you
can script against them right like you
can program against this API next cloud
beta product has the clusters that will
build on top of compute engines and
there is like this data proc agent that
manages its sort of control plane and it
manages your cluster you know make sure
that we M syrup and things like that
right and the this also the image that
we have is built on top of big top so it
comes with a spark do I've and many
others things that are there when the
cluster is brought up we also bring up
some persistent disks and we install the
HDFS on them or make them available
through HDFS however if you want to use
the start use stop cycle you cannot
really keep the input and outputs on the
HDFS because it goes away when you're
done so what you do instead is you use
your you put your inputs and outputs on
on cloud storage and bigquery on one of
these services that are always helpful
but not like but the gods come down and
up with your cluster okay so at some
point on a break day last year in our
regular performance analysis things we
notice a problem and the problem was but
for a big the jobs accessing a big
amount of data on GCS the read and write
were spending a lot of time in SSL
related code so much more that it wasn't
bottleneck on network but was
bottlenecked on cpu operations right
like we're a bottleneck on cpu remember
i said like that we recommend to GCS
door users this was a surprising so we
analyze it
and determined the java-based ssl
implementation is very CPU bound okay
and once we identify the problem we you
know could come up with a 50 solution
momentarily that would you know help the
people who are affected make it run
better but we really wanted to do it in
a systematic way to make it available to
all of our users and that meant that we
needed a system level solution okay that
will be deployed to everyone and will
make everyone's life better not just a
few that we you know that we're
complaining that things are slow so
what's the solution the solution was the
switch implementation too boring SSL and
because it's boring is a cepheus boring
name I had to have a unicorn this portal
so what it involved well you know quite
a bit of things but essentially what we
will over the next few weeks the old
data proc customers will have
significantly improved as a read and
write performance to GCS and essentially
these are the results so we're looking
at a test DFS i/o benchmark x axis is
throughput we you know the more the
merrier so you want a higher throughput
and light blue is the old method and the
dark blue is the boring ssl method right
and essentially we are seeing two times
two and a half times faster prefer reads
and around twenty percent faster rights
and there are no user changes it's just
like the new system configuration the
drums and the different jobs will see
different benefits because if your job
was in bottleneck on desk this is not
going to significantly improve it right
because your end time depends on more
than just this but this is another
example of like you know systematic
improvement that goes in a system and if
you were watching your application over
time can you know will make it cheaper
and more efficient to run okay
okay so i'll have some takeaways now so
when they're trying to achieve the
performance and you want to do that
automatically for your data processing
applications the tools have to look at
the different types of factors right we
have application level factors
environmental factors and system factors
we try to systemically less all three of
them across both of these products and
across with JCP right performance is
something we care about and we'll look
at all the time we have dedicated people
for that right in our talk we covered
the application aspects and environment
aspects and how we deal with them
through data flow looking at the dynamic
worker balancing out of scaling the
graph optimizations we do and on a
system side we'll look at the data proc
and how they improved one of the core
system libraries by replacing it
essentially to bring the performance to
increase the performance of freedon
rights to GCS which is a very common
pattern that our users used so data
processing tools help your plea your
application achieve performance
automatically which is thematically
tackles different factors that affect
the performance and will we provide real
time out to tuning in cloud dataflow and
system-level improvements in cloud data
proc and improvements made to the
systems until we make improvements to
the system controls continually so we
take the performance available to out of
the box and the note knobs are needed
[Music]
[Music]